it's been 16 years since the first Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater came as they finally
got around to making a fifth one and he
suddenly feels very old 1999 man crazy
night Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 is it
today by no means the fifth Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater game we played a bunch for
this morning it's come out its
controversial yeah let's let's break it
down okay Justin you haven't played any
won't be the first question you have
about me and on to your plate of the
bunch
well I played it a little bit um so so
why is this the game that's coming back
after oh I think people really
gravitated toward skate Vittorio due to
a very different style of controlling
like Tony how it feels like a throwback
throwback in a lot of ways is is this
the kind of experience that you guys
wanted after how well-received skate was
I'm a massive fan of Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater I'm a huge fan of the skate
series I think skate series is probably
like top five best sports games of all
time in probably in there what would
honk a little bit um I think it's just a
matter of that game was very much
catering to the skateboarding crowd like
that was to people who like care about
like nailing you know shove it over a
three stare as opposed to telling hawk
which is kind of this like skate culture
melange of like music and and like
popular skaters and interesting maps and
sort of you know crazy modes and
objectives so to me it's like Oh
Activision had this thing this is the
right time to bring it back.this and
Guitar Hero why not yeah what I'm kind
of surprised the bed is that this is a
$60 game because that game Tony Hawk's
one or two or three incredible games
that game released nowadays isn't the
type of experience that you because it's
very repeatable so it doesn't feel like
the type of game that you'd spend $60 on
that would be charged flat especially in
2015 when you've got games are charged
$0.99 the whole way up to $50 and
everything in between or 60 and
everything in between so that's the way
in which I think this game feels a
little bit weird
does this feel like a 60 dog game to you
so far Andy no
and I know that the HD remake wasn't yes
Yannick kind of feels that caliber
although it like seems to work a little
bit better like overall but I was
actually thinking like it when I was
doing okay so first point when I played
Tony Hawk 5 for the first time it was
like a couple weeks ago and yeah we were
doing a little demo and I didn't have it
I was like what happened I'm not and I
kind of blamed the game yes
doesn't feel like Tony Hawk's doesn't
feel like oh and then last week we were
working on our big thing about Tony Hawk
and we played a bunch and we played on
ps3 the original game with the like
backwards-compatibility yeah and that
the same thing happened I was like oh
this is 15 years later my brain has
changed my hands are changed like I
can't do this [ __ ] so I was like ok so
it's not the game it's me I just suck
really bad so have you gotten used to it
now I've gotten back and do it after
playing a lot from the original games
and then this morning we were playing a
lot and like I'm not nearly as good as
you because you had a lot of like
practical games and you were like
slaying those down and then you're
slaying this down and then it's like ok
I started picking this back up started
feeling it and it feels it's like oh
yeah this feels good yeah so definitely
the main words I think that they've done
is that now when you hit the grind
button it basically slams you yeah and
we were like maybe that's bad but you
can correct yourself off of vert ramps
where you go off and it's like you're
gonna land flat yeah and then you like
it kind of reorients you in which is a
nice little feature but it definitely
changes the flow so like if you're like
jump words before you'd hit triangle to
basically queue up a grind so you do it
click you do a jump and your bed to hit
one you'd hit triangle and by the time
you hit it it's like it knew you hit
triangle yeah where's now if you do it
it basically almost like snowboarding
style you like you pressure down to like
sort of like it's sliding back yeah ok
so that changes up the game a bit and
and then outside of that that's kind of
I guess let's break this down this is a
game where you sort of it's kind of more
in the realm of Tony Hawk's 3 where
you've got as much time as you want in
these areas and you basically go up to
objective markers that are litter around
the map and then there are things like
ok here's the part where Tony's gonna
share moves at you and you have to do
the tricks or here's a bit where you
have to like do as many manuals as you
can into
or you know get as many vert scores as
you want and in the first level here in
the barracks which is Reynolds's real
skatepark down in MLA you know that's
like okay like these are like tutorial
II kind of objectives that they're
trying to teach me except then I went to
the next level and I was almost the same
objectives just in a place like there
was one here when you're in this pool or
sorry in the in the barracks where it's
like they fill the pool off all the
balls yeah big inflatable balls and you
have to get used to like skate into them
and get rid of them and get them on it
and that's kind of fun it's like a neat
little diversion except that I went in
school three which is like the new
version of school too and there's a pool
inside and I can't let the balls are now
sports balls from school but you still
have to get rid of them so like now I'm
a little bit worried that there's like
that much repetition yeah and I avoided
they like objective base stuff when I
was just free skating guys just free
skate and I found that to be good and I
was like oh this is toned down as far as
like the crate like you don't spin as
fast like I wasn't spinning sevens you
can really like bubble three kicks
website or either yeah you gotta like
the boy like go a little easier and like
really plan out your in routes and like
yeah if you plan on you really should be
rewarded really well and like it'll be
awesome
but then I like hit these ramps in
school too yeah just like arbitrarily
long see oh yeah and then I was spinning
sevens no problem and then like when you
hit the special you do like a multiple
you can like it just basically turns all
your tricks and their specials yeah kind
of cool which is weird but then those
are like more fantastical where like
it's not skating back to you do a
compliment that he does a cry stare
because you're in like special mode cool
is it yeah isn't that fun yes Prince I
just was I just wasn't sure where the
where it was on the spectrum and now
yeah yeah it's more Tony Hawk yes still
Tony Hawk it's just you gotta like find
those spots that launch you to in order
I still haven't spun 9 like it it does
feel though I was talking to Jeff
Gerstmann from Giant Bomb right before
we came on and and he was saying that
they're getting reports they know that
big patch that arrives the first like
day one patches like as big as the game
whatever like I made seven gigs party
that has most of the game in it and it
kind of does feel like a game was
finished about a week ago because like
the UI stuff is super weird like for
instance if you go up to Anna
active marker you have to stop right
beside us like knowing you can't get off
the board
if the snubber and then hold down X it's
not like Burnett where you could like go
in the realm of it and then hold X and
it'll start just go right there and when
you do that for some reason like the
menu swaps from the analog stick to the
d-pad you're like okay and it's the
weird stuff like when you start
objectives sometimes I don't clue what
I'm doing the first time I kind of have
to figure it out for myself like is one
right - like Tiki lamps I didn't really
tell me anything about where they were
and then I was like no you can't you're
inside the objective or you go back here
so it seems very rough around the edges
now the thing that's getting the most
attention right now are people having
horrible glitches that's what's getting
shared around on the idea is is that
what you guys been experiencing not at
all no I think we've seen one in the
past two hours but then we've only been
doing so we haven't played online and
we've also not been doing the maybe
that's a big one and we've not been
doing the like we'd be great at
creatively yeah Park so all the created
levels apparently that's where that's
that's where the so does your video edge
where people are going through the floor
and all that sort of stuff
but I haven't seen that happen in the
three levels that we played anyway so it
doesn't seem like the total hot mess
that the Internet's making it out no no
no but it's also $60 mess it's like
never this is like Peters reviewing at
first this is real like Midland Road I'm
enjoying it because it's like a big
nostalgic yeah I'm genuinely enjoying
this and will genuinely probably try and
like 100% this game like really kind of
like I mean it's like a tree skating I
don't know if I'll ever do this mission
to unlock the levels though so I got to
do that in witnesses Gary it's weird
though because they have things like
create a skater mode or there's no like
slaw for you to create somebody you just
have to edit an existing skater which
seems weird it's just super lice and let
it enter Reynolds yeah Andrew Baumer
it's like I don't really like nyjah
huston I guess I'll just change I'm
about the same height as him I'll just
do that here low County yeah it's it's
weird it's it's like I feel like I'm
enjoying it mostly out of the fact that
I'm a big Tony Hawk's Pro Skater find
and also because I think I came in with
this with such low expectations that I'm
actually kind of pleasantly surprised
that it's it's kind of alright so maybe
not the best introduction though for
people who don't have that nostalgia who
didn't grow up with Tony Hawk no no
I can't I don't even know who that is
yeah I got you know what I grow my skate
or die okay yeah yeah how's that make
you feel a little bit younger no it
makes me just feel older that's like
older older older older so if I played
skater die
it's yeah it's oh it's I'm brain into
the super reviews for this game because
I can see it like sliding completely non
opposite ends and it's kind of like
we're talking about the car games
earlier so much of it goes dancer what
Andy was saying of the stars like does
this feel right yeah just feel like I'm
in control of what I usually blame the
game for being terrible no Dan ride
spent over the diner I can't he was like
this does not feel like it something all
came to me yeah but see he's remembering
wow I bet it's that happen to me I was
like when you go back and play Resident
Evil you're like oh man this is like
impossible to control I've totally
forgot that game or like the original
tomb Raider but the version you have in
your head of how the original tomb
Raider played is like totally different
to the reality of it so I wonder if the
game looks very Arkady and that's kind
of what I remember is Tony Hawk being of
the an arcane II version this kind of
game and feels like it's gonna live up
to that yeah I just worry that I really
don't think it's a $60 game like is it
gonna be better than Tony Hawk ride when
you had that yes controller there was
the Martin that was the ski board I can
confirm right now that it is better than
Tony Hawk ride and the thread shred was
a lot huh yeah I think that had
snowboarding ends oh oh tired yeah
there's a snow break level in it well
there's a mountain Oh level yeah so
we'll see I think we have to got a lot
some more and unlock them all and see
you had the rest of the ice but yeah
early adopters is really does not feel
like a $60 proposition but I guess we'll
find out what keeps putt calm thinks we
assume Peter banners reviewing Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater five and and that
review will be up sometime this week if
these are more playing to do because we
didn't get an early copy as well which
is always a little bit of a concern but
if you've played us or seen people play
it or a big fan of series or looking to
get into it let us know what you think
in the chat and in the comment box hello